Manille, côté vitrine.
Sa baie touristique, ses promenades
et ses quartiers d'affaires.
Manille, une mégalopole avec
ses enfants des rues.
Venus de la banlieue
ou des lointaines campagnes,
Ce sont des enfants abandonnés,
drogués, battus, qui voient dans cette ville
la promesse d'une vie meilleure.
On estime qu'ils sont entre 200 000 et 300 000,
Passant leurs journées à errer,
mendier, voler,
Dans cette ville qui n'est plus qu'un mirage.
Sans espoir, ils font partie du décor.
C'est à peine si l'on fait
attention à eux.
Pour couper la faim, ces gamins inhalent
de la colle ou fument du c****.
Une façon d'oublier un peu la galère.
Une image ordinaire à laquelle les autorités
philippines ont décidé de s'attaquer.
Cacher cette détresse qu'on ne veut pas voir,
C'est depuis quelque temps le credo officiel.
Alors, pour nettoyer les trottoirs, la mairie
a mis en place un service de ramassage.
Curieux mélange de travailleurs sociaux
et de policiers.
C'est ici, loin du centre ville,
derrière ses murs barbelé,
Que la mairie a décidé de cacher ces pauvres.
Deux bâtiments vétustes,
Une prison pour enfants et en face, le RAC,
Reception Action Center,
Un centre social d'accueil,
en fait une prison qui ne dit pas son nom,
Où sont parquées toutes les personnes
ramassées dans les rues.
Une majorité d'enfants, des mamans esseulées,
Et beaucoup de vieillards au bout du rouleau.
Cela fait 15 ans que Dominique Lemay intervient
ici tous les jours avec sa fondation Virlanie.
Forte de ses 30 volontaires bénévoles.
Père Dominique, comme on l'appelle ici, essaie de
rendre la vie des enfants plus supportable.
Le RAC a commencé à l'intérieur
de la prison pour enfants de Manille.
Dans cette prison, il y avait donc
2 cellules à ce moment là,
Et on mélangeait les enfants
qui avaient été détenus,
Avec les enfants qui venaient de la rue.
En 1992, il y avait ce bâtiment là,
Qui était en très mauvais état.
On l'a refait pour en faire un accueil
pour les enfants des rues,
Ce qui évitait que les enfants des rues soient
incarcérés dans cette prison pour enfants.
Aujourd'hui, activité décoration et nettoyage
pour les enfants.
Le RAC fait peau neuve.
On attend une princesse, Caroline de Monaco,
princesse de Hanovre,
Est ici en tant que présidente de
l'Association mondiale des amis de l'enfance,
La MAD, dont la Fondation Virlanie fait partie.
Alertée par Dominique, elle vient se rendre
compte elle-même de la situation,
Mettant tout son poids dans la balance
pour que le droit des enfants soit respecté.
Le maire de Manille en personne
s'est déplacé pour l'événement.
À la grande surprise des résidents du RAC,
Plus habitués à le voir sur des affiches
qu'en chair et en os.
Le protocole est bien réglé et même
les enfants prisonniers se prêtent au jeu.
Et maintenant on souhaite la bienvenue
à la Princesse Caroline.
Il faut dire qu'en échange d'un bon accueil,
on leur a promis une séance de basket.
Ils sont entassés à plus de 50 dans une cellule,
sans savoir quand ils sortiront.
Beaucoup sont ici depuis plusieurs années,
À part certains qui ne sont pas des anges,
Le seul délit de ces ados a été
d'avoir traîné dans la rue.
Monsieur le Maire, Prinncesse, elles
réclament à être libérées avant Noël.
Pour qu'elles puissent aller
retrouver leurs familles.
Elles sont là depuis combien de temps ?
On est là depuis 2 ans.
Je pense qu'on vous a compris, 2 ans
c'est probablement suffisant.
Après la prison, visite du RAC.
Ici, le plus vieux pensionnaire a 81 ans.
Le plus jeune, à peine un mois.
Ils sont venus à quatre ici parce que sa mère,
Avait vendu une des filles de sa famille,
à un réseau.
Donc elle est partie de là pour
ne pas être vendue par sa mère,
Avec son bébé dans un réseau.
Elle est protégée ici,
pour éviter justement le trafique.
On essaye d'avoir une promesse que la
plupart des enfants sortiront avant Noël.
- C'est ce que vous avez dis au Maire ?
- Oui, le Maire s'est engagé.
Vous avez parlé de livres ?
Oui, leur donner accès à des livres,
à de la lecture...
C'est difficile de voir exactement
ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui,
parce qu'ils étaient au courant
de notre arrivée.
Le lendemain de la visite de la princesse,
la vie retrouve son cours normal,
L'ennui, la routine reprennent le dessus.
Seule animation de la matinée,
Le ballet des fourgonnettes blanches qui déposent
leur lot quotidien d'enfants ramassés dans la nuit.
Des enfants déboussolés aux parcours compliqués,
Que les autorités locales
ont bien du mal à comptabiliser.
À priori, en ce moment la rumeur,
c'est que le maire de Manille voudrait faire
en sorte que tous les gamins soient fichés,
Répertorier tous les gamins des rues,
En leur donnant un genre
de petite carte d'identité,
Pour pouvoir contrôler les arrivées
d'enfants qui viennent de province,
Qui vont potentiellement devenir
des enfants des rues à Manille,
Le fait d'avoir des enfants
qui ont des ID,
ils sont à Manille, on sait, ils ont leurs papiers,
On essaie de les renvoyer en province
parce qu'on a leur immatriculation.
Tous ceux qui viennent, qui n'ont pas leurs papiers,
vont être renvoyés à la périphérie de Manille,
Est-ce que tu sniffes des solvants ?
Oui, ça m'arrive d'en prendre.
Depuis combien de temps, un mois ?
Non, ça fait un an.
Donc là, par exemple, c'est un gamin
qui s'est enfui de chez lui.
À priori il y a un problème de famille, c'est
un peu le truc classique des enfants des rues,
C'est à dire qu'ils s'enfuient,
Parce que ils sont battus,
ou la famille a tellement d'enfants qu'ils ne
peuvent pas le nourrir, par exemple.
Il n'y a pas de considération.
Ça va assez loin,
une espèce d'ignorance du gamin.
- Et toi tu sniffes de la colle ?
- Non, j'ai pas de vice.
Ils veulent pas nous laisser sortir,
nous on veut déjà partir.
On veut rentrer chez nous,
on est déjà triste ici.
Ce qu'ils veulent, c'est partir. Ils
ne pensent qu'à une chose, c'est partir.
Il y a des chances qu'ils s'enfuient
d'ici quelques jours.
C'est comment la vie dans la rue ?
On se fait toujours tabasser par les adultes,
on se prend souvent des coups de poing.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux faire plus tard ?
Comment tu vois ta vie dans le futur ?
Je veux être Maire.
Il veut être maire !
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il aura une vie moins dure.
Parce que le Maire il peut aider pas mal
de monde, surtout les pauvres.
Il fait construire des maisons
pour ceux qui n'ont pas de toit.
Pourquoi tu veux être policier ?
Il veut être policier parce que lui,
il est gentil,
Donc ça fera un policier gentil.
Quand les gamins arrivent, pendant 3, 4 jours,
Ils ne sortent pas, donc enfermés
dans les cellules.
C'est soi disant un temps d'adaptation.
C'est pour formater les enfants
pour éviter qu'ils s'échappent.
Mais beaucoup ne sortent jamais et restent
isolés toute la journée,
Comme les ados de la prison.
Ils ont mis au point entre eux un
code, un langage des signes,
Qui leur permet de communiquer
de cellule à cellule.
Le reste du temps est occupé à manger,
dormir, s'ennuyer dans des cellules exiguëes,
où les centimètre carré
sont âprement disputés.
Le pacte avec les adolescents prisonniers
a été respecté,
Ils ont droit à leur partie de basket.
Mais le temps est limité. Tout est fait pour éviter
de les mélanger avec les plus petits, ceux du RAC.
Emmanuel, un autre volontaire, veille à ce
qu'ils se croisent le moins longtemps possible.
Alors en fait, ces enfants sont la plupart
du temps dans des cellules, enfermés.
Et c'est le seul moment de la journée
où ils peuvent sortir et se défouler.
Ce qui est difficile,
c'est que dans les cellules,
Il y a à peu près une cinquantaine
d'enfants de cet âge là,
On est obligé de choisir entre 15 et 20 enfants
par période d'activité,
Et on est limité à 2h.
Chaque enfant peut se dépenser
pendant 2 ou 3h par semaine uniquement.
Là, il y a des petits bouts de chou,
Ils ont des tee-shirt
qui font deux fois leur taille.
Des fois, quand ils courent,
ils sont obligés de tenir leur short,
parce que c'est beaucoup
trop grand pour eux.
En fait, ils ont une vie vraiment difficile,
Mais quand ils jouent,
ils sont vraiment des enfants.
Je prends beaucoup de plaisir
à faire du sport avec eux.
Alors lui, en fait, c'est un enfant qui est handicapé.
On les appelle des autistes.
On m'a dit aussi que c'était un psychotique.
Il ne participe pas du tout aux activités
parce qu'en général,
Il est toujours dans sa cellule
et il passe son temps à pleurer.
Et il n'y a absolument
aucune prise en charge.
Le staff ici n'est pas forcément formé
à s'occuper d'enfants handicapés.
Il est complètement livré à lui-même
et il n'est pas du tout simulé,
Il se retrouve complètement seul.
Comment tu t'appelles ?
Tu veux jouer ?
Ok, passe-moi la balle.
Quel est son nom ?
Le petit garçon a dit
que c'était un psychotique.
Ici, on les appelle par leur particularité.
C'est comme les personnes de couleur,
on les appelle les n****.
Lui, on l'appelle un psychotique
et souvent on les appelle les spécials,
Les enfants spéciaux. C'est comme
s'ils n'avez pas vraiment d'identité.
Sans attaches familiales, sans papiers,
Beaucoup de ces enfants ne connaissent
même pas leur nom.
En général, l'administration leur
en donne un composé de quelques syllabes.
En dehors de ces 2h de basket hebdomadaires,
La vie ordinaire du RAC,
c'est ici qu'elle se déroule.
La cour, les couloirs et les cellules.
Cela fait trois mois qu'Agnès est ici.
Sans aucune nouvelle de sa famille.
Seul moment d'évasion,
la lecture avec son petit frère,
D'un magazine que nous lui avons donné.
Je voudrais qu'on soit plus emprisonné ici.
Qu'on ait suffisamment à manger.
Qu'on ait du temps pour jouer.
Et qu'on ait la télé dans notre salle.
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce que je m'ennuie.
Comment tu te sens ici ?
Prisonnière.
Ça s'est passé un soir, j'ai dit à mon papa :
"Papa je vais à l'épicerie du coin."
Un monsieur est venu vers moi, il m'a dit :
" Viens ici petite fille, je vais te donner,
du chocolat, il m'a entraîné vers un coin
sombre et d'un seul coup, il m'a attrapé.
Je me suis mise à crier et il m'a dit :
"C'est pas la peine, personne va t'entendre ici."
Il m'a donné un coup de poing dans le ventre
et il m'a dit : "Si tu te laisses pas faire,
je vais te tuer et si tu me dénonces
je vais revenir te voir et tuer ta famille."
- Qu'est-ce qu'il fait ton père dans la vie ?
- Il prend du k****.
- Et ta maman ?
Elle est malade après son dernier accouchement, on
lui a posé un stérilet et elle est malade depuis.
Agitation inhabituelle dans la cour du RAC.
Une quarantaine d'enfants se trouvent soudainement
embarqués dans la fourgonnette de la mairie.
Choisie un peu au hasard,
sans explication.
Ils vont dans un centre de désintoxication.
C'est ce qui s'est passé les derniers jours,
Ils ont fait des rescue missions pour tous
les gamins qui sniffent de la colle,
Qui fument l'équivalent du c****,
Et ils les emmènent tous là.
Ce qui est assez curieux, c'est qu'il y a des
gamins qui sont là depuis beaucoup plus longtemps,
Je ne sais pas, je ne comprends pas
trop ce qu'il se passe.
À l'étage, Agnès a compris.
Son petit frère se trouve parmi les enfants.
Le seul lien familial
qui lui restait vient de partir.
Elle sait qu'il va retrouver
un enfer encore plus terrible,
Et qu'elle ne le verra pas avant
six mois, dans le meilleur des cas.
Un retour qui dépend du bon vouloir
des autorités locales.
Prendre soin des enfants
est une activité excitante.
Parce que nous croyons,
Le maire pense que les enfants de Manille
représentent la plus grande des ressources,
Et même s'il y a des enfants des rues,
des accros à la colle,
même s'ils sont abandonnés, négligés,
ils restent notre ressource.
C'est pourquoi nous travaillons dur
pour leur donner un avenir meilleur.
Parce que le maire de Manille considère que
l'espoir de notre pays, ce sont ces enfants.
Même si vous les voyez comme des enfants
de rue, cela reste des enfants.
À la différence des pays européens,
Où certes, vous avez des endroits magnifiques
avec des cathédrales, de belles églises, des musées,
Mais vous ne voyez plus d'enfants.
En France, il paraît même que vous avez
plus de chiens que d'enfants.
Pour Dominique et son équipe de volontaires,
C'est un rapport de force permanent
avec l'administration philippine.
un combat quotidien jusqu'aux moindres
détails, comme ici,
avec un retard de réparation
dans les sanitaires.
Mais c'est pas vrai !
Ils m'ont dit dans les toilettes des garçons,
le toit est tombé et ils ont fermé.
La semaine dernière, j'ai piqué
ma gueulante parce que j'ai dit,
Quand ils étaient en bas en réunion,
le staff de l'équipe,
Je suis monté et j'ai vu 70, 80 enfants
dans la grande pièce du haut,
sous une chaleur épouvantable, sous un toit
en tôle, vous voyez ce qu'il peut se passer,
Agglomérés là dedans...
Et je crois que là, il y a tout
un travail à faire,
Pour que l'équipe de salariés
de cette institution,
Comprenne que c'est pas rester assis
sur leur chaise ici en bas,
Que la condition des enfants en haut changera.
On enferme, on incarcère
et puis on met un verrou,
On met un cadenas comme ça,
on a la paix.
Ça ne fait rien s'il y a une bagarre à l'intérieur
de toutes façons on n'est pas dans le coup,
Il n'ont qu'à régler
leurs problèmes eux-même.
Ouvrir, éveiller l'esprit des enfants,
Ne pas les considérer comme des numéros.
C'est toute la mission
de la Fondation Virlanie,
Qui a réussi à imposer une salle
de classe au sein du RAC.
Les enfants des rues apprennent des rudiments,
Oublient un peu l'univers carcéral
et peuvent même, de temps en temps,
S'inventer un autre avenir et rêver.
Autre nécessité, la santé.
Ils avaient envie de partir pour pas
que les Social worker l'emmène ailleurs.
Il s'est complètement taper contre le mur.
Il s'est fracasser la main.
C'est cassé.
C'est la première fois que je vois
quelqu'un qui s'auto mutile de la sorte,
Pour pouvoir partir du RAC en fait.
Mais ça ne m'étonnerait pas
qu'il y en ait plusieurs qui le fassent.
C'est vrai que la plupart du temps
ils préfèrent vivre dans la rue qu'ici.
Pour Lyne, une volontaire néo zélandaise,
il y a urgence, du matin au soir.
Ces journées n'ont plus de limites tant les
pathologies sont nombreuses et variées.
Il y a un peu de tout.
Il y a les petits qui ont juste
un petit morceau de peau arrachée.
Ils veulent un peu de lotion rose,
un bisou et ça va.
À l'autre extrême, j'ai vu une femme
qui mourrait devant moi par terre,
elle avait perdu connaissance,
elle avait un cancer du sein.
Elle avait du liquide vert qui
sortait de la bouche et du vagin.
Elle mourrait devant moi comme ça.
Moi, je pense que c'est une entorse négligée.
Elle a fait une chute.
Il faudrait immobiliser son genou.
La santé des gens ici...
C'est pas une priorité du système.
C'est pour ça que Virlanie, justement,
a introduit,
Une composante qui était
partiellement négligée.
Il est important de savoir qu'on
les gêne dans leur comportement.
Les volontaires me disent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là ?
Mon équipe de salariés me dit :
Mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait au RAC ?
On a qu'à les laisser faire !"
Mais on n'a pas le droit de laisser faire.
Si on les laisse faire, déjà, les droits
des enfants sont pas beaucoup respectés.
Alors si on part, je pense qu'ils
ne seront plus respectés du tout.
On est là aussi pour les bousculer.
Je crois beaucoup à ça, moi.
Et pour bousculer les autorités, Dominique
mise beaucoup sur la visite de la princesse,
qui les a placés devant leurs responsabilités.
Un signe à la fin de la visite,
Le maire s'est engagé à faire
un geste pour les enfants avant Noël.
Avant Noël de quelle année ?
Moi, je peux vous assurer aujourd'hui
que je vais tout faire.
On va se battre ensemble pour que ces rêves,
Et ces promesses faites
à la princesse soient réaliser.
Les rêves... Cela fait longtemps que les
enfants perdus de Manille n'en n'ont plus.
Mais un coin du voile aura été levé.
Va-t-il se refermer ?
Agnès, elle, attend toujours des nouvelles
de son petit frère.